inflation is surging around the world at
the fastest pace in decades but prices
are rising much faster in some countries
than in others even though all countries
are dealing with the same issues
disrupted supply chains higher fuel
costs and the end of covet 19 lockdowns
so what makes the difference let's look
at a few countries and some factors that
have contributed to their varying levels
of inflation
china the world's second largest economy
is seeing the lowest level of inflation
relative to its inflation rate before
the pandemic of any country in the world
in fact inflation was lower in china in
the second quarter of 2022 than it was
in the first quarter of 2020 but a major
reason for that is china's economy has
taken a big hit largely from coveted
lockdowns that began in early 2020 and
have continued through this year
the country's economy which had grown by
five to ten percent a year over the past
decade grew by just 0.4 percent in the
second quarter
and it's on pace for one of its weakest
growth years in recent history the
people's bank of china kept interest
rates higher than most throughout the
pandemic even as other central banks
were cutting rates to help boost their
economies
mexico is doing better than most
countries on inflation its inflation
rate in q2 was double what it was in the
first quarter of 2020 but that's well
below the average for large countries
around the world
its central bank started raising
interest rates in june 2021
well before many other central banks and
raised them faster mexico's government
spent relatively little in stimulus
refusing to borrow significant amounts
of money to underpin the economy even so
the mexican economy grew at a faster
pace in the second quarter than it did
in q1 2020 and grew at almost four times
the rate of other large countries in the
organization of economic cooperation and
development or oecd
inflation in the united states has more
than quadrupled from where it was in the
first quarter of 2020 putting it
slightly ahead of the average for other
oecd countries and growth has declined
in the first two quarters of this year
the u.s had the most recorded deaths
from covet 19 in the world spent more
than 5 trillion on stimulus programs and
its central bank cut interest rates to
zero and didn't start to raise them up
again until march of this year
greece has been one of the worst hit
countries by inflation
in the second quarter greece's inflation
rate was 28 times higher than it was at
the start of 2020 and hit an all-time
record the european central bank kept
interest rates negative throughout the
euro zone during the pandemic even as
the greek government spent heavily as in
much of europe russia's invasion of
ukraine has caused gas power and food
cost in greece to skyrocket
like many eurozone countries greece is
seeing higher levels of growth than much
of the world but it's also seeing higher
levels of inflation and unemployment
one common theme for countries with
muted inflation was a fast-acting
central bank
but it's not a perfect science
japan's central bank kept rates negative
through the pandemic but it has seen
limited inflation central banks around
the world are now aligned and raising
interest rates
we'll find out if that's enough to get
inflation under control
hip-hop legend nipsey hussle had some
great advice for times like these he
said follow my steps and you'll see what
i'm about i keep my money coming in
and never going out
that's all for now see you next time